i've seen a lot of crazy insane amazing
things in the bitcoin community but this
email that i just saw has to be one of
the most awesome things i've seen any
bitcoin company or product do here's the
details the ontario superior court of
justice asked a self-custody wallet
provider nunchuck to disclose user
information and freeze users bitcoin as
part of all the crackdowns in canada but
here was the team's response which is
absolutely epic dear the ontario
superior court of justice
it's a self-custodial collaborative
multi-sig bitcoin wallet we are a
software provider not a custodial
financial intermediary our software is
free to use it allows people to
eliminate single points of failure and
store bitcoin in the safest way possible
while preserving privacy we do not
collect any user identification
information beyond email addresses we
also do not hold any keys therefore we
cannot freeze our users assets we cannot
prevent them from being moved we do not
have knowledge of the existence nature
value and location of our users assets
this is by design please look up how
self custody and private keys work when
the canadian dollar becomes worthless we
will be here to serve you too sincerely
the nunchuck team this is absolutely
epic not only do they explain that their
technology is built in a way that will
not allow them to create surveillance on
their users or freeze those users assets
but they also say that this technology
this software this open source software
is available not only to the nunchuck
users but it will also be available to
the government to their employees and to
anyone else in the world that wants to
use it that's the beauty of bitcoin is
that bitcoin is not only for those that
are sympathetic to not only those who
are educated on bitcoin is also for your
enemies for your adversaries and for
your critics everyone is going to need
bitcoin and so ultimately it is the
community's responsibility to make sure
that we're building software in a way
that's open source and that cannot be
overrun by government or by any sort of
legislative procedure nunchuck proves
that ultimately their technology they
cannot surveil their users they cannot
freeze their assets regardless of how
much pressure is put on them the
technology is censorship resistant the
technology is built for dissident
and all of a sudden that became really
important in canada kudos to their team
this was an epic email my guess is we're
gonna see more of this moving forward